[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son los invitados y Con
quienes conversamos sobre algunos de los
hechos más destacados de la semana hemos
invitado en esta oportunidad a Daniela
pastrana ella es periodista y directora
de pie de página punto mx está en la
Ciudad de México en la capital de la
República Mexicana Daniela Bienvenida al
programa Gracias por acompañarnos Y qué
tal termina usted su semana
gracias gracias por la invitación y
Bueno pues nosotros terminamos acá en
México todavía no terminamos tenemos una
semana muy muy muy ajetreada con el
regreso la reincorporación a las
actividades del presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador que tenía covid hoy se hoy
se reincorporó una más con una agenda
recargada y tenemos el fin de de la
agenda legislativa Nada más con
diecinueve iniciativas que debe aprobar
el senado Entre hoy y el domingo
Entonces digamos que en México está
agitado anda muy agitado por estos días
agenda la agenda no va a terminar este
fin de semana con todo lo que hay
pendiente allí en México Bueno pues
Daniela Gracias por acompañarnos en esta
oportunidad y paso a presentarle a
nuestro otro invitado que también está
en la capital mexicana él es Fausto
pretelli Muñoz él es editor de la
sección internacional de el economista
Fausto un gusto tenerlo en el programa Y
qué tal termina usted su semana ya
sabemos que la información en México
Pues no va a parar hasta el domingo
qué tal Santiago Daniel un gusto
saludarles pues ya lo comentaba Daniela
muy laberíntica esta semana aquí en
México
y en el mundo por supuesto Creo que vale
la pena arrancar con estos temas no
muchos muchos temas para analizar a lo
largo de esta semana pues bueno también
le pido a nuestros televidentes que
acompañen Este programa estas
discusiones y estas conversaciones con
opiniones y comentarios y también
preguntas por supuesto a través de las
redes sociales nos encuentran como
arroba
franz24_s@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral una semana en
el mundo f24 todo pegado todo junto para
que dejen sus comentarios y sean parte
de el programa entramos en materia
comenzamos en el extremo sur del
continente bueno en el norte de
Suramérica digámoslo así en Colombia
exactamente porque este país estuvo en
el foco de la actualidad internacional
Poco después de dar por concluida esa
Cumbre internacional sobre Venezuela que
tuvo lugar en Bogotá en la capital
colombiana tema de que también vamos a
hablar en el programa de hoy el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
pidió la renuncia protocolaría de todos
los ministros para anunciar una
reestructuración de su gabinete la
renovación ministerial también dio pie a
una ruptura de las alianzas con los
partidos tradicionales y también sirvió
para impulsar los Pilares de su llamado
gobierno de el cambio comienzo entonces
preguntándole a Daniela en la capital
mexicana impresiones allí en México cómo
se vivió este remesón político en
Colombia y también Supongo que había
expectativa en torno a esa conferencia
en torno al tema de Venezuela porque
precisamente México es un actor
importante en esta en esta negociación
con Venezuela porque es uno de los
países que ha sido sede de los diálogos
entre oposición y gobierno
sí tenemos que recordar esto no México
ha sido
partícipe de estos diálogos y también
México ha sido un país que o sea se ha
reclamado pues que no haya que no haya
habido esto flujo
pactado en esos en esos diálogos
Entonces es un momento delicado es un
momento en el que creo que
México y Colombia están compartiendo eh
elementos que yo veo parecidos no O sea
están por un lado con unas dinámicas
internas de reacomodos y de incluso de
radicalización de ciertas posiciones
internas
y por otro lado con una activismo
internacional interesante hacia la
conformación de estos bloques aquí en
México se anunció esta misma semana la
alianza la alianza
no la alianza sino la agencia la idea de
crear una agencia no para
la soberanía de de medicamentos y se
anunció justo en la conferencia
presidencial que es una plataforma
importante y en esa en esa misma Alianza
en esa misma agencia están también
Venezuela y Colombia lo que quiero decir
con esto es que
eh Hay un activismo intenso hacia hacia
afuera que están compartiendo el tema de
Venezuela está siendo tema constante en
la agenda internacional de de la región
Y
pues lo que están viviendo y lo que se
está viviendo hacia dentro de los
gobiernos parece que es como si
tuviéramos no sé como dos
formas paralelas no como se ve muy bien
hacia afuera lo que se está haciendo en
algunas cosas creo que Petro ha hablado
muy bien de
gobierno del presidente López Obrador
acá se habla muy bien de de lo que están
haciendo allá pero internamente los
países están teniendo muchos problemas
para gestionar sus su su sus proyectos
con las oposiciones no en el caso este
lo que acabas de decir es es claro o sea
se rompe Esa esa idea de la coalición
Petro pues ni siquiera está cumpliendo
un año tiene poco tiempo él en Colombia
hay cuatro años para para hacer los
cambios que quiere hacer Y entonces opta
por la vía de
afianzar a la gente que con la que ya ha
trabajado antes para poder sacar
adelante eso su su gestión y Fausto su
opinión sobre este tema este remezón
político en Colombia
Fausto bueno las crisis es cuando se
conoce Sí sí lo escucho
s
vamos a retomar entonces la conexión con
Daniela mientras restablecemos la
conexión con Fausto que tiene algunos
problemas con la conexión vamos a a
mirar Cómo podemos mejorar esta conexión
de a través de internet para retomar la
conexión con ellos sigo entonces con
Daniela Daniel y retomo algo de lo que
usted estaba mencionando que me parece
certero al mirar diferentes ejemplos en
América Latina y es que de puertas para
afuera se ven gobiernos muy bien
afianzados tratando de liderar en sus
respectivas casas digámoslo así y así es
como se ve de puertas para afuera como
decía usted pero al interior de los
países vemos a gobiernos y hemos a
presidentes que les cuesta mucho
afianzarse en el poder y sobre todo
sentar las bases para que en sus
gobiernos pues se puedan tomar
decisiones
y hay remociones y ahí
revolcones de gabinete como vimos en
Colombia pero es lo que estamos viendo
por ejemplo en Argentina en Chile donde
hay que cambiar ministros hay que tomar
medidas rápidas se toman decisiones
apresuradas Perú que todavía no logra
asentarse políticamente y Colombia Pues
ahora viviendo Este cambio de ministros
solamente nueve meses después de haberse
instalado el gobierno eso que qué
síntoma le da a usted que al gobierno le
cuesta afianzarse o que es parte
simplemente de este proceso de
adaptación a llegar a la jefatura del
estado
no lo que yo creo Es que es parte de un
proceso que está viviendo el mundo y la
región este compartimos las mismas cosas
y efectivamente O sea no solo es eso es
la polarización política la polarización
social a estos gobiernos progresistas
les ha costado mucho Encontrar el punto
medio entre sus proyectos sus proyectos
para disminuir la brecha social dentro
de un mundo global dentro de un mundo
que ya tiene reglas y dentro de un mundo
que ya está funcionando De cierto modo
entonces encontrar un punto medio de
equilibrio hace que
dentro de sus países quienes apostaron
por cambios radicales no los vean o sea
no puedan tampoco apoyar una serie de
medidas que están haciendo que en las
oposiciones tampoco los estén viendo con
buenos ojos y al final están gobernando
también con
con Pues con con lo que tienen se ha
visto que no es suficiente los cuadros
que tenían al llegar al gobierno para
tener un gobierno nacional que pueda ser
efectivo en todas las medidas no
entonces todas estas contradicciones las
estamos viendo repetirse en todos los
países de la región no es una cosa de un
gobierno eh No han encontrado esa
fórmula y están intentando no pero pero
sí efectivamente no no vemos como como
lidian con esa contradicción y vemos y
vemos una una disputa y también
muchísima polarización en torno al
cambio muchas personas votan y apuestan
por ese cambio pero hay personas
reticentes Al cambio eso genera
muchísimos choques a nivel social y lo
vemos en diferentes países de América
Latina Fausto lo tenemos de nuevo en el
programa adelante Contamos con su
opinión adelante
Sí a ver yo lo que le decía es que se le
acabó la luna de miel al presidente de
Colombia a Gustavo Petro ha cometido dos
deslices a nivel internacional el
primero de ellos fue haber anunciado un
ces el fuego por el eln la guerrilla y
no fue así es decir en pocas horas
respondió la guerrilla que no que no
había llegado Esa esa negociación esa
conclusión el segundo desliz creo que lo
vivió esta semana en una convocatoria
con oposición de Nicolás maduro y del
propio Eh Pues de varios países de
varios países que de alguna manera
quieren Pues que se sienten a la mesa a
negociar las próximas elecciones que
sean transparentes transparentes
increíbles creo que no supo manejar la
crisis de Juan guaidó guaidó llegó de
manera pues ilícita ilegal a Colombia
Colombia pues lo despachó prácticamente
lo embarcó lo llevó a un avión y lo
despachó para Venezuela para Miami en
ese sentido creo que el gran examen para
Petro será creer o no creerle en la
palabra Nicolás Maduro Nicolás Maduro ha
o ha estado participando en más de
quince mesas de negociación y Nicolás
Maduro sigue al frente del gobierno es
un dictador en ese sentido creo que ha
sido bastante Absurda la idea de creerle
inclusive el propio gobierno de México
piensa que sí va a haber una negociación
limpia y transparente y que de alguna
manera Nicolás Maduro va a querer unas
elecciones limpias falso falso por
supuesto y en ese sentido creo que Petro
internamente ahora también es la primera
crisis que recibe y vemos como de alguna
forma se le ha acabado la luna de miel
hay que ver que Colombia estuvo durante
dos décadas gobernada por el uribismo
creo que es una transición difícil la
que está viviendo y que la va la que va
a vivir y vamos a ver si Gustavo Petro
tiene un perfil de un de un estadista de
un presidente que necesita conciliar
internamente a muchas fuerzas del del
país porque el congreso el congreso no
es suyo Fausto y a nivel interno usted
lo dice le está costando mucho al
presidente Petro crear consensos
convencer a muchos sectores políticos
tal vez lo que todavía no se termina de
entender se lo digo porque estoy en
Bogotá en este momento
es entender a qué está jugando Petro a
nivel internacional sirviéndole de tanto
apoyo a Venezuela Cuál es el interés de
regresar a Venezuela al escenario
internacional y el ser este gran
abanderado de ir a vogar por ellos en
escenarios internacionales y Y
prácticamente pues llevar una agenda que
va enrutada hacia eso aquí hemos hecho
análisis sobre eso lo he conversado con
otros colegas periodistas y no termina
uno de entender cuál es el interés que
puede tener Petro con esa relación con
Venezuela tan estrecha cuando como usted
mismo dice maduro mueve las piezas del
del ajedrez como quiera y ya para esta
nueva mesa de negociación en México Ya
empezó a poner condiciones y condiciones
muy difíciles de cumplir
Sí a ver yo creo que el problema
fronteriza que tiene con Colombia y
sobre todo lo que heredó del uribismo eh
hace posible esa Reconciliación entre
Colombia y Venezuela sin embargo está
tomando una postura más de relaciones
públicas con la casa blanca Es decir
tratar de negociar con biden la idea de
que desmantelen las sanciones económicas
que le ha impuesto Estados Unidos desde
que llegó Donald Trump a la presidencia
vimos que biden se acercó a Venezuela
inclusive cuando inicia la guerra en
Ucrania precisamente pensando en los
energéticos una visión muy pragmática
del presidente Estados Unidos y también
está la otra parte que es la oposición
la oposición está inmadura es una
posición o posición fenómeno venezolana
que ha cometido graves errores Empezando
por Juan guaidó no tiene ya el apoyo de
los 56 países Por supuesto que tuvo al
inicio de esta sesión o de esta de esta
presidencia en sombra si se le puede
llamar en ese momento y gran parte de la
culpa también la tiene la oposición En
ese sentido creo que Venezuela es una
crisis muy fuerte pero pero creo que
Petro ha tratado precisamente de de de
de de poder desmantelar esa crisis no es
decir de ayudarle a a Venezuela y la
gran el gran examen va a ser si va a
haber o no elecciones limpias Ese es el
gran el gran examen mi respuesta
evidentemente con Nicolás Maduro no se
puede confiar él tratará de quedarse
todavía en el poder y sin embargo bueno
la gran la gran el gran examen también
está en la oposición ya los capriles los
no tienen ninguna vigencia y será un
examen para Colombia Daniela si esas
elecciones a las que les está apostando
el gobierno de Petro a nivel
internacional de abogar por este esta
conciliación a nivel internacional este
apoyo para fomentar esas esas elecciones
limpias será una prueba difícil para el
presidente Gustavo Petro y para ese
liderazgo de Colombia que ese es hacia
donde va enrutada la pregunta que le
quiero hacer el liderazgo de Colombia a
nivel continental ustedes como lo ven
ustedes que están en México porque vimos
años atrás al presidente Duque con una
estrategia muy distinta aislar a
Venezuela a nivel internacional
liderando este cerco diplomático ahora
Colombia cambia de posición cambia de
tendencia política y hay otra estrategia
con Venezuela ahora es tratarlo de
llevar otra vez al escenario
internacional como ven ustedes ese
liderazgo de Colombia en
desde México desde desde otra óptica
entendiendo lo que está haciendo este
país Daniela
Bueno entonces le pasó la palabra a
Fausto sobre este tema
bueno a ver yo creo que empezó con
muchas expectativas Petro Es decir desde
México vimos que el uribismo ya estaba
agotado ya no tenía de alguna manera un
planteamiento hacia adelante
Iván Duque digamos que no fue o no tuvo
liderazgos de sus antecesores y en ese
sentido creo que la izquierda puede que
por vez primera llegaba a Colombia
generaba cierta expectativa no sabíamos
cuál iba a ser el comportamiento ya del
presidente Petro sabíamos que venía de
una izquierda radical de una izquierda
más de la guerrilla
y que no no podría de alguna manera
continuar con Esa visión
precisamente por lo que está ocurriendo
en la región no es decir en medio de
dictaduras como la es venezolana La
Cubana la nicaragüense en medio de de
crisis económicas como la Argentina de
una ultraderecha o derecha que estaba
bolsonara cuando cuando llega Petro la
calle está Lula pero ahora en la región
sí se ha cargado hacia la izquierda y
nos hemos dado cuenta que hay varios
tipos de izquierda no es el mismo borich
que el mismo Petro o que Lula veinte
años después que también ha cometido
errores a nivel internacional en la
actualidad pero el liderazgo de de Petro
creo que ese es el gran examen si a
nivel internacional logra tener
acercamientos con diferentes potencias
lo mismo Estados Unidos la Unión Europea
china inclusive
podría de alguna manera pues tener
cierto crecimiento a nivel regional en
la región Santiago hemos estado
prácticamente
sin liderazgos desde que llega López
Obrador también se pensaba que iba a
crecer a nivel regional Fue totalmente
un fracaso a nivel internacional y
regional es decir no tiene un perfil
internacionallista Lula es el que ha
sacado un poco la cabeza en las últimas
semanas con el intento de negociar con
Rusia
se ha Aliado con china se ha acercado
mucho con china lógicamente Brasil pero
Petro maestro le apostó a Venezuela como
usted menciona quizás no había tanta
expectativa o por qué muchas razones
alrededor de esa decisión creo que la
razón era brasear en contracorriente del
uribismo creo que él quería Petro sacar
la bandera de que iba a ser conciliador
con Venezuela un un país pues además de
vecino muy cercano y que al abrir la
frontera pues se iba a ver también una
apertura de oxígeno democrático en
Venezuela no le hemos visto y ojalá que
no sea tan no le vaya a creer Petro a
Nicolás Maduro de que sí tiene
intenciones de hacer elecciones limpias
no las tiene Y a partir de esa premisa
hay que empezar a ver qué pasa allá en
Venezuela en las próximas sí pueden ser
una de las de las opciones me llama la
atención y con esto Voy cerrando este
tema de Colombia es esa lucha no sé si
lucha pero pero sí hay cierto cierta
intención por parte de lule por parte de
Petro de tomar ese liderazgo de la
izquierda por lo menos en la de
Suramérica un liderazgo que tampoco tomó
Gabriel Boris que se veía muy impulsado
al inicio de su gobierno y vemos a Petro
con una agenda también muy internacional
yendo a la casa blanca haciendo estas
conferencias con representantes de casi
20 países en Bogotá una agenda muy
nutrida a nivel internacional de hecho
la próxima semana viajará a España para
reunirse con el gobierno español y con y
con el rey
allí en Madrid para hablar de de temas
pues bilaterales y de inversión de
España en Colombia y viceversa y es un
poco también lo que está tratando de
hacer Lula a nivel internacional
muchísimo relacionamiento volver a
Brasil a la escena internacional tal vez
se puede inferir que Petro va como en la
misma línea dándole un poco de
visibilidad a Colombia a nivel
internacional Fausto hemos perdido la
conexión con Daniela también la vamos a
retomar más adelante continuamos
conversando usted y yo y pasamos a
hablar de el siguiente tema que tenemos
en la agenda hecho destacado de esta
semana el presidente de Estados Unidos
anunció su candidatura oficial para la
reelección para el año 2024 esta
decisión abierto el debate sobre si su
avanzada edad impide el desarrollo
óptimo de sus funciones como presidente
de Estados Unidos El mandatario ha
destacado sus logros también las metas
que quiere cumplir y por eso pues ha
hecho en su discurso y en su mención
sobre esta reelección una frase clave
que la recojo en esta introducción Y es
que busca terminar el trabajo Quiere
cumplir con esa ambiciosa agenda que
tiene de múltiples factores y aspectos a
mejorar en Estados Unidos ahora la
pregunta es quién será entonces su rival
del lado republicano quién puede ser esa
figura que haga contrapeso en esas
elecciones y y pues se enfrente al
presidente Joe biden en esa disputa por
mantenerse en la casa blanca primer tema
para analizar sobre este tema Fausto la
edad mucha controversia en Estados
Unidos en torno a la edad del presidente
citó un titular de un diario local un
diario pequeño regional que hacía la
siguiente pregunta to all to remate in
Office muy viejo para mantenerse en el
cargo le parece usted que es muy viejo
para que el presidente biden seque otros
cuatro años en la Casa Blanca
bueno a ver yo creo que las expectativas
que tenía el presidente cuando llegó a
la casa blanca era de un presidente
transición un presidente que iba a
transitar a su país de un estado caótico
que heredó del presidente Donald Trump a
un estado en donde se respete la
institución presidencial creo que le
gustó quedarse y también hay una
ausencia de liderazgos en el partido
demócrata creo que sí le da es muy
avanzada hemos visto un presidente que
no viaja mucho al exterior el presidente
Estados Unidos Generalmente viaja mucho
al exterior al mundo sube baja Escaleras
No tiene el dinamismo no tiene la
capacidad ya motriz para poderse mover
como un presidente y un líder tiene
frente así una guerra en Europa tiene
frente así un América en donde china
está presente cada vez más y tiene
frente Sí ese dilema que es decir china
está mirando a Taiwán En ese sentido
creo que desde política exterior el
presidente está muy cansado es un
presidente ya mayor de edad tiene
ochenta años llegará o dejaría la a los
85 años de edad aproximadamente pero la
gran pregunta Santiago aquí es que pasó
con Camila Harris es decir que era hace
tres años hace cuatro años la la
prospectiva de una figura demócrata que
que pudiera llegar a participar en las
elecciones del 2024 pero no fue así
anticipo que se hará unas elecciones
aburridas serán unas elecciones en donde
quizás su contendiente sea Donald Trump
Daniela hemos retomado la conexión con
usted ansiosos por conocer su opinión
sobre la edad del presidente Joe biden
muy viejo para mantenerse en la casa
blanca qué piensa usted
sí aquí tuve un problema con con
internet mire Sí yo coincido en buena
parte de lo que dice
mi colega
no en el tema de la edad precisamente
porque en México acaba de morir uno de
los intelectuales más consolidados que
hay que es Pablo González Casanova tenía
ciento un años y estaba plenamente
entonces creo que la edad puede ser un
factor relativo Pero lo que sí creo Es
que el presidente biden está agotado
está o sea más allá de la edad que tenga
está agotado no no me parece que el
hecho y eso es preocupante no el hecho
de que sean
paiden y Trump las las nuevas cartas de
la elección de Estados Unidos habla de
un serio problema de crisis de los
partidos eh de en Estados Unidos no no
puede entenderse que no tengan unas
opciones
pues más atractivas para enfrentar las
serias crisis que está teniendo porque
efectivamente Y si lo que hemos visto es
que Estados Unidos ha perdido buena
parte de la de la hegemonía que tenía
para muchas cosas frente a la emergencia
de China y frente a otras cosas y
entonces estamos viendo que esta crisis
se ve reflejada en lo que van a por si
unas elecciones sumamente
desangeladas yo creo Daniela y Fausto
que me abono esa opinión de ustedes que
esto van a hacer unas elecciones muy
aburridas porque van a ser caras
conocidas no hay una renovación política
y
Daniela le traslada una pregunta que
estaba planteando Fausto y es Qué pasó
con kamala Harris pensábamos que ella en
estos cuatro años de primer mandato de
biden o de este mandato de biden se iba
a formar como la sucesora del presidente
biden para las próximas elecciones de
hecho retomando lo que dice Fausto ella
es la que está viajando es la que está
visitando los países es la cara más
jovial de la Administración biden muy
cercana con la gente muy criticada por
supuesto pero pero qué pasó se quedó en
la mitad de camino esta formación como
una sucesora Qué pasó allí
Bueno pues yo me sumo a la pregunta no
tengo la respuesta Este pero claro era
era lo que
hace cuatro años todo todos esperaban no
O sea justamente se esperaba que vayan
fuera un presidente de transición
después de este gobierno desastroso de
Donald Trump y pues que íbamos a ver en
en algún momento llegar a a la a una
mujer presidenta a al gobierno de
Estados Unidos pero pues esto estamos en
Las mil con la misma pregunta o sea es
en qué momento perdió la fuerza
suficiente o en qué momento dejó de
tener eh apoyo para poder plantear una
candidatura propia No eso es una cosa
que yo no tengo claro
y me parece muy lamentable O sea me
parece que en en temas importantes como
podrían ser por ejemplo el tema del
aborto en Estados Unidos y en una serie
de cosas tener una mirada fresca más
joven podría claro feminista o femenina
o como queramos llamarle podría haber
sido algo que pues emocionara pues en en
las elecciones sobre todo a Los
Seguidores del partido demócrata Claro
que emocionar a ver caras nuevas energía
política renovada y una mujer disputando
la Casa Blanca Aunque bueno Nicky hayley
puede ser una nominada por el lado
republicano pero pues los ya veremos
Cómo cómo avanzan esas primarias y si se
puede postular y lograr esa nominación
para el cierre de este tema rápidamente
Fausto un aspecto positivo de la
Administración biden haciendo un poco de
balance y negativo las dos caras de la
moneda
Bueno yo creo que el aspecto positivo ha
sido el gran programa
de salvamento de la economía no es decir
los cuatrocientos mil millones de
dólares
contra la inflación y a favor de la
producción de los chips internos es
decir son dos programas en realidad que
hacen flotar a Estados Unidos que han
ayudado económicamente y que de alguna
manera también se hace un análisis
geopolítico es decir frente a China el
tema de taiwanes peligrosos sabemos que
Taiwán produce seis de cada diez
semiconductores en el mundo y Estados
Unidos está poniendo mucho acento en ese
tema importante ese tema y el lado
negativo rápidamente el lado negativo es
la salida de Estados Unidos de
Afganistán fue un desastre que son
todavía se siguen pagando las
consecuencias y Afganistán está sumido
en una crisis sobre todo las mujeres
afganas son las que han sido olvidadas
tema muy complicado que hemos analizado
aquí en France 24 Daniela sus dos caras
de la moneda
Bueno yo coincido mucho en este sentido
o sea creo que aunque el tema de la de
la economía es un poco con pinzas no
está bien pero a el costo ha sido
también un poco alto con el tema de la
de la de la inflación y las medidas que
han tenido que tomar pero yo creo que
ese es como la parte que que digamos es
salvable no no es un desastre y en el
tema del de la de la cara mala aparte de
lo de Afganistán yo creo que la política
migratoria O sea no ha logrado
el presidente va a llevar a cabo una
política migratoria que tenga un sentido
o sea va dos pasos adelante uno para
atrás otro para adelante otros dos para
atrás
van sentidos contrarios no logra
concretar sus acuerdos Y creo que o no
logra concretar sus sus iniciativas ni
sus problemas ni sus promesas y creo que
ese ha sido uno de los grandes problemas
que además impacta a toda la región y le
juegan contra la coyuntura de la con
muchos problemas sociales en
Centroamérica en el Caribe yo le
añadiría a ese punto positivo la gran
inversión infraestructura que Estados
Unidos lo necesitaba para seguir siendo
competitivo frente a China y Europa
negativo yo me atrevería a decir esa
falta de Liderazgo internacional Europa
lo ve como un Aliado que no saben si hoy
está mañana no está no no es muy
definido el rumbo como Aliado
internacional para muchos países para
otros y Bueno aquí en América Latina lo
vemos Ya ahora como un Aliado muy lejano
porque nos tienen completamente
olvidados avanzamos con otro tema
pasamos a nuestra sección de el
comentario lanza un tema de ustedes
simplemente hacen un comentario sobre
sobre el tema que les voy a plantear Y
eso nos lleva a Suramérica porque este
domingo Paraguay va a elecciones
generales el gran interrogante es si el
tradicional partido Colorado se va a
mantener allí en el poder luego de
ocuparlo durante casi siete décadas casi
que de manera ininterrumpida Entonces
les pregunto a los dos invitados
comienzo entonces con Daniela para hacer
la ronda la inversa perspectivas de lo
que vaya a pasar en Paraguay que tal vez
es un país que no tenemos mucho en el
radar político pero lo que está en juego
en ese país nos tiene a todos en el
balcón mirando Atentamente lo que sucede
en Asunción
si están dos
están muy muy encontrados Está muy
difícil definir quién puede ganar
también están ahí muchas divisiones
internas tanto del partido Colorado como
de esta Alianza opositora y yo al final
lo que creo Es que en ninguno de los
casos va a ser una opción que tenga o
que logre tener la mayoría de
digamos el agrado de la mayoría de la
población paraguaya está muy fragmentado
o sea está dividido en dos bloques no
pero al final muy fragmentado Sí y con
la con la población muy apática frente a
estos a estos comicios Fausto su opinión
su comentario sobre Paraguay
bueno parece un símil a la mexicana es
decir el partido Colorado es como el pri
décadas y décadas gobernando Y de alguna
manera también ya la gente se va
aburriendo internamente está muy divido
el candidato Santiago Peña con el
presidente ebdo y eso en ese sentido
ardo perdón y en ese sentido creo que
puede perder muchos votos la inseguridad
Está creciendo en el país y eso le da
pie a la oposición está a gran alianza
que tiene para poder pues tratar de
ganar las elecciones Será muy difícil
porque el congreso será Colorado Será
muy difícil porque la infraestructura el
andamiaje político de Paraguay está
hecho a semejanza de lo que es el
partido Colorado se necesita una un
cambio radical Cerramos el comentario
doy paso al siguiente comentario Porque
en estos días está siendo celebrada la
Feria Internacional del Libro de Bogotá
y también comenzó la feria del libro en
la ciudad de Buenos Aires en Argentina
yo aprovecho entonces para preguntarles
a nuestros invitados que están leyendo
qué les gusta en la literatura en este
momento qué es lo que los tiene ahora
devo
páginas de libros en sus lecturas Yo veo
que Daniela tiene una biblioteca
bastante grande detrás de usted
sí me gusta mucho leer Pues yo ahora
estoy leyendo un libro que se llama la
invención de los sexos de luchísia que
es una
biotecnóloga Argentina muy interesante
que nos plantea muchas dudas en torno a
cómo se ha ido construyendo la idea de
los dos sexos en el tema este del
binarismo y también estaba leyendo un
libro que que conseguí hace poco
justamente en Venezuela que es los tres
libros de Rómulo Gallegos es que es Doña
Bárbara canaimas y canto claro y son una
delicia La verdad sí delicia y muy
interesante ese primer libro que nos
estaba mencionando Fausto que está
leyendo usted que tiene entre manos
bueno parece que no hay nada aquí atrás
pero sí me gusta mucho
libro de Mario maravillosa que es el
diario de un decidio que es sobre la la
historia de la vida y la obra sobre todo
de
de del Gran del Gran escritor de Cien
años de soledad de Gabriel García
Márquez es un libro que de alguna manera
publicó en 1971 sin embargo Parece ser
que después de las de los pleitos que
tuvieron ellos dos salió de circulación
hace un par de años lo volvieron a
editar y es auténticamente una una obra
de arte porque habla a fondo de cuáles
son las inspiraciones que tuvo García
Márquez a la hora de escribir
particularmente Cien años de soledad
pero también hojarasca también varios de
sus de sus de sus libros Entonces es
ampliamente recomendable es magnífico
Bueno pues muchas gracias por estas
recomendaciones yo les dejo un dato que
me ha pasado mi compañera Rosa Pérez que
ha colaborado en la producción
periodística del programa de hoy me
pasaba este dato que me parece
interesante traerlo a la mesa láser lag
que es el Centro Regional para el
fomento del libro en América Latina y el
Caribe nos dice y le pregunto a ustedes
dos y cuáles son los la cantidad o el
porcentaje de libros que lee una persona
en un año en los países de América
Latina cuál cree de Daniela que es el
país que más en América Latina
Wow es una pregunta difícil no no quizá
Argentina pues es correcto si
estuviéramos en un programa concurso se
hubiera llevado el premio mayor del
millón de dólares Argentina y chile son
los países en donde sus habitantes más
libros leen por año 5.4 libros al año en
Argentina 4.5 en chile y le preguntó a
Fausto también La otra cara de la moneda
cuál cree usted son los países que menos
libros leen al año
bueno incluyendo el Caribe sí
Haití posiblemente es el de los países
que menos Lee libros
hay una correlación quizás en temas de
economía perdón sí de de economía
y no sé no sé quizás Honduras
pues Yo lamento decirles que México es
el penúltimo con dos coma nueve libros
por año leen sus habitantes pero peor
aún Colombia 2,2 libros al año somos el
país que menos libros lee al año en la
región de América Latina esto dice mucho
del tipo de sociedad que tenemos en
América Latina sociedades que no que no
leen mucho teniendo unos autores
fascinantes pues ya lo saben la feria
del libro de Bogotá Ya está presente
también el stand de France 24 donde
ustedes pueden acercarse a obtener
información de la cadena allí También
estaremos haciendo algunas entrevistas y
algunos programas y bueno y disfruten de
la feria también en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires para el cierre Daniela y Fausto
vamos a preguntarles Cuáles van a ser
esos temas que van a tener bajo la lupa
bajo el radar para la próxima semana en
sus redacciones Fausto adelante Bueno yo
creo que Ucrania sigue en el radar
internacional muy atentos de lo que
pueda llegar a ser Lula también pero
sobre todo en este tema será de alguna
manera un elemento fundamental y bueno
lo que está lo de Estados Unidos también
es importante
que como sabéis perfilando estas
sanciones o estas estos juicios que
están en contra de Donald Trump vamos a
ver si si pueden hacer algo en contra de
él o no y creo que esos son los dos los
dos temas importantes y Daniela sus
temas para el cierre
pues yo voy a estar muy atenta a las
actividades de Francia Marx en África
que puede ser muy controversial pero
para mí es un tema que tiene que ver con
de colonización y anti racismo y es un
tema importante tema importante yo les
pongo sobre la mesa esa gira del
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro a
España como parte de todo este periodo a
nivel internacional por supuesto Ucrania
siempre va a seguir siendo un tema
importante en la gente internacional las
elecciones en Paraguay la próxima semana
estaremos analizando Quién ganó Y quién
va a llegar entonces a la presidencia de
ese país suramericano en donde hay tanto
en juego y añado también vamos a estar
muy pendientes a lo que pasa en España y
Portugal en torno a la ola de calor que
va a afectar a ese país en los próximos
días y bueno me uno también al tema de
Daniela la gira de Francia Márquez por
algunos países africanos que genera
mucha expectativa no es común que un
mandatario un representante Un gobierno
latinoamericano esté haciendo una gira
extensa como la que va a ser Francia
Márquez por el continente africano
Daniela Fausto un gusto tenerlos con
nosotros en el programa Muchas gracias
por habernos acompañado hoy buen fin de
semana para ustedes
Igualmente muchas gracias bueno Y
ustedes Pues muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado les recuerdo que pueden
seguir dejando los comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
la producción del programa estuvo a
cargo de Andrés doncel la producción
periodística hoy tuvo la colaboración de
Rosa Pérez mi compañera en la redacción
de France 24 y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera sigan con nosotros sigan en
France 24
[Música]